good morning John Wow it's been a really
long time since I saw this seriously
Wow Wow Wow I used every other day and
now it's like every other week and I'm
just like I have like 400 ideas for
making videos and none of them we're
gonna get done because I don't have the
pressure anyway I can't talk about right
now because there are things that I have
to discuss tomorrow is a very important
day
now this video is mostly going to be
about America's Super Tuesday primary
elections so people who are interested
in politics and people who aren't in
America should drink it pay attention
because this is of international
importance to every single person on the
earth because one of these five people
is going to be the President of the
United States in like a year and like
exactly half of those five people scared
this bit out of me
now another might be strange to have
half of five people scattered out of you
but it turns out that half of John
McCain stares this me but the other half
doesn't that's how he makes me feel
Romney and Huckabee they scared me all
the way yeah like if River tan from
Firefly teamed up with the new
Terminator from the new Terminator show
and their entire campaign platform was
just kick angry ass that would not scare
me more than a Huckabee Romney ticket no
I would take that ass beating from both
that kind little ass beating girl and
that evil little ass beating girl I
would take it for America okay okay what
I'm trying to say is that nothing would
scare more bit out of me then
Republicans in the White House again and
there's a lot of talk about how it can't
be much worse than it is now oh yes yes
it can it can it could be much worse
than it is now but the real question for
me for John is which Democratic
candidate do we choose we got Hillary
she's a woman and that's awesome and I
love the idea that there'd be a woman
president United States that'll be
awesome she's got the experience she was
in the White House for eight years
she got connections she knows how it
works she's jacked into the whole thing
then we got Obama and he's black and
it'll be like amazing to have a black
president
it's like ready to take on the system
and I'm gonna be President and they're
not gonna tell me
how to run things I don't need to know
how they run things I'm gonna run things
my own way I'm gonna make this country a
better place with my awesomeness and I
got a say uh like in the way that he
talks cuz I got a man crush on Obama
beat to the 8th to the arc AC K OB ama
sorry Hillary John and I are pretty much
both Obama guys now but that doesn't
mean that they have the nerdfighter
endorsement nerdfighters are of every
color race creed and even political
persuasion there are Republican
nerdfighters I do not deny it I know
that I will get many negative comments
from my disapproval of the Republican
platform but there it is generally they
don't recognize that the environment is
an issue John McCain the one who does
has a much weaker plan on climate change
than either Barack or Hillary such is
life and if anybody's curious about how
the primary Kennedy stack up to one
another in terms of environmental issues
actually my company just launched a new
blog called enviro walk eat to the end
to the VAR o wo n K calm we've just done
an analysis of all the candidates the
basic gist of it is that Hillary and
Obama are very very similar Obama seems
to be a little bit stronger than Clinton
but they're both much stronger than
McCain and the rest of them just don't
even think about it they don't talk
about the environment they talk about
energy independence which mostly
includes drilling all over America
trying to get more oil out of the ground
since oil is kind of yeah the problem
may be drilling for more is not the
solution and any of you who think that
McCain is not going to continue the work
that Bush is doing ah maybe take a look
at this picture and realize not the
candidate for change that's all for me
john wants to do a question Tuesday is
possibly not on Tuesday but on
Wednesdays so if you want to leave your
questions for John in the comments
please do he will answer them on Tuesday
or possibly went ape down I'll see you
on Tuesday or possibly Wednesday